[Music]
Hollywood loses one of the most famous
teen idols ever David Cassidy and no
show spent more time with Partridge
Family icon and et did David shared with
us the good times and the bad because
the years after teen started yeah that
is certainly true but we will always
remember the joy his music brought the
world an awful lot of people come up to
me now and talk to me about the impact
that I had on their lives in the 67 year
old was surrounded by family when he
passed away in a Florida Hospital he had
been in critical condition for six days
and his organs were failing
[Music]
the sitcom that launched him to fame was
about a family band but the Partridge
Family success was always tough for
David to deal with it was a dream and a
nightmare at the same time I felt
flattered by it but I also was
frightened by because it there was a
realist area Oscar winner Shirley Jones
played his TV mom it was actually his
real-life stepmother today his TV
brother Danny Bonaduce tweeted he has
been as kind to me as any real brother
could ever be this loss is huge
[Music]
later in life things went downhill for
David although he continued to perform
on stage he struggled with alcoholism
you have to know I'm sick inside I want
to get well and for me it was about I
don't want to live another day and this
kind of help feeling this kind of pain
in recent years he battled dementia and
sometimes forgotten lyrics while
performing but during his final
interview with et just last year he told
us that being on stage gave him life I
gotta stay on this road cuz this is life
this is love and this is health and I
still have a job to do that is here and
here that makes me want to continue to
inspire people
[Music]
you